cardi B shares her trick to mastering
the perfect thirst trap pick the 27 year
old rapper who has a reputation for
being totally transparent with her fans
shared this pic poolside looking fit AF
in a teeny bikini but she jokingly
revealed in the caption I sucked the bit
out my stomach for this a day later
cardi posted this video strutting her
stuff showing off her seemingly taut abs
but once she turns to walk outta frame
she seemingly it releases her tummy back
to its normal state captioning the clip
suck it in life but let's be clear cardi
looks amazing whether she's sucking it
in or not her fans agree many praised
the Bronx native in the comments writing
this is why I love you cardi and same
says Santa right now and I don't know
how the [ __ ] do it like I'm I am so
hot
damn I feel dizzy and all that lord I
mean my colour is coming out really
really pretty but between getting back
in the studio sucking it in and snapping
pics poolside the Grammy Award winner
has been busy working on her tan
I'm not going to side with another day
have been I up for 30 minutes [ __ ] can
bacon I feel like a crab leg [ __ ] is
hot off her is easy feeling good parties
also been spending plenty of time with
family as she splits her time between
Los Angeles and Atlanta they've been
partying and eating good
[Music]
Blanco by Hennessey
cardies relatability is what we loved
about her the girl has always been an
open book my daughter Mia she did she
said do when et spoke with her last year
she got real candid about her body and
the cosmetics procedures she underwent
after giving birth to her first child
culture you just made this big
revelation about getting liposuction why
was that important for you to share uh
it was important to me to share you know
what a lot of people was just like
egging me on to do it even though I was
going to do it because I really want to
explain to people how hard is to process
I feel like a lot of people look at
girls on Instagram and think like oh
they got the lipo done and it was so
easy and this is such a long hard
process it's almost like the same
process as after you give birth to a
baby and you seen your body change and
snap in your back it's the same way but
I will talk later about it more I don't
mean a documentary maybe I should start
filming it right I should start filming
I should start filming the process
because this crazy
[Music]